what i hope to do in this video is start
with an exponential expression that's in
a fairly straightforward form and then
turn it into one enough hairier form and
let's actually just do it i'll i'll show
the initial expression in the form that
i want it in or that we want it in and
we could talk a little bit about why
would we ever actually want to do that
so let's say my expression is 1
30 seconds
times 2 to the t power so this is fairly
straightforward exponential expression
but let's say we want it we want it in
the form
a
times b and this is where it's going to
get hairy a times b to the t over 10th
power
minus 1.
and so you're probably immediately
saying why would i ever want to take
something nice and simple like this and
turn it into this beastly thing right
over here and the answer is when you get
into higher math and you start doing
your physics and your chemistry you're
going to see maybe you know you got a
result like this but then you look in
your textbook or your professor
has a result like this well how do i
transfer from this to this or actually
sometimes when you transfer to a form
like this obviously i've just
arbitrarily written this form here but
sometimes when you tr when you write it
in another form that might even be a
little hairier it can give you an
intuition on the underlying processes
that that expression is trying to
describe so if you can take that on a
leap of faith let's actually try to do
it at minimum it's going to make you a
lot better at exponent properties so see
if you can rewrite this in this form
so i'm assuming you took a go at it so
let's try to do it together
so the first thing that the first thing
that i might want to do is
well let's see if we can
let's see what would i want to do the
first thing i want to do is take this t
and get it into a t
let's get it into a t over 10. so to do
that
we essentially just need to multiply by
10 and divide by 10.
so let's multiply by 10 and then also
divide by 10.
then we haven't changed the value up
here so we can rewrite this we can
rewrite this as
1 32nd
132nd
times 2
to the
so let me circle t
let me just in a different color
t
over
over 10 times 10
times times 10.
all right so we got a t over 10 over
here but then i have this times 10. so
how do i how do i deal with this
well one thing that i could do let me
just let me actually just write this the
other way around let me write it as
let me write it as
times t over 10
10 times
t
over 10. so hopefully this what i just
did here isn't a huge stretch here i
just literally multiplied and multiplied
and divide by divided by 10 so i have
this t over 10. but when i write it this
way an exponent property might jump out
at you if i have
if i have a to the b and then i raise
that to the c that's going to be a to
the b c or another way around a to the b
c is going to be a to the b
to the c
and so
this piece right over here i can rewrite
it as
2 to the 10th
and then raise that to the t over 10
power
to the t
over 10 power once again 2 to the 10th
and then raise that to the t over 10
that's going to be the same thing as 2
to the 10 times t over 10. and of course
we still have the 1 over 32 over here
over
1 over 32. and i'm tempted to write that
as 2 to the negative 5th power but i
won't do that just yet
so let's see what's 2 to the 10th power
actually let's just let's just keep it
let's just keep it as 2 to the 10th
power just for simplicity right now
later we can you might know that that's
going to be 1024 but let's just let's
see what else we can do so we know this
is going to be some actually let me just
write out as 1024. so we have 1 over 32
times 1000
to the t over 10
to the t over 10 power
so it seems like we're getting close we
did we if there was no minus one here
we're essentially done but now there's
this minus one so how do we deal with
that
well we can do a similar type of
strategy we can subtract one
and then we could add and then we could
add one then we're not actually changing
the value just as we multiplied by 10
and divide by 10 we're not changing the
value up here if you subtract one and
add one to the exponent you're not
changing its value and so what is this
going to be we want to leave this minus
1 here but we want to get rid of we want
to get rid of this plus 1 somehow
and here we just have to remind
ourselves that if we have a to the b
times
a
to the c that's going to be equal to a
to the b plus c if you have the same
base multiplied
same base raised to different exponents
and you multiply them you could just add
the exponents and so you could also go
the other way around if you have a to
the b plus c you could break it up into
a to the b times a to the c
so
this business right over here
this business right over here this is 10
24 to the
t over 10 minus 1
plus
1. so we can break this up as
we can break this up as
10 24
24 to the t
over 10 minus 1 that's this part here
and then times 10 24 to the 1
times let me make this in a different
color so
let's see green
so this right over here so times
times 10
24 to the one power that's this one
power right over here and of course we
still have the 1 over
the 1 over 32. all right so now we're
really close we have the 1024 to the t
over 10 minus 1 we have t over 10 minus
1. and now we just have to simplify we
can rewrite this is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to we could
just bring the 10 24 10 24 to the first
power that's just 10 24.
so that's going to be 1000
over
i can put all these commas here if i
like 1024 over this 32
let me do that magenta color
over
this 32
times
home stretch
times 10 1024
to the t over
to the t
over 10
minus one power and now we could just
simplify this you must you might
recognize 10 24 we already saw that that
was the same thing as 2 to the 10th
power
32 is the same thing as 2 to the fifth
so 2 to the 10th divided by 2 to the
fifth actually this is another exponent
property at play here although you could
just divide the numbers if you have if
you have a to the b over a to the c this
is going to be equal to a to the b minus
c
so this is going to be 2 to the 10 minus
5 or this whole thing
this whole thing right over here
this thing actually i wanted to do that
in a different color this thing
is just going to be
2 to the fifth power or 32 so this is
going to be 32
times 1024
one
we were in the home stretch here
1024 to the t over 10
minus 1. so once again normally in our
lives we like to make things simpler and
i'm a big advocate of that it's a good
life philosophy but this is a case where
we really did make it more complicated
we started with one thirty second times
two to the t actually we could have well
there's other ways we could have written
that and we turned it into this thing
with this somewhat hairier exponent but
it's a useful skill to have because you
might get a result like what we
originally started with and then someone
else might get a result like this and
it's very important to realize hey you
actually got the same result they're
just different ways of expressing the
same exponential expression